all right tonight we are still awaiting
Robert Muller's next move to reports are
expected before the end of the week
including new information on the special
council's coordination with Michael cone
and as well as findings from the
neverending saga surrounding Paul
Manafort oh you had nothing to do with
Russia neither case has anything to do
with collusion and on Tuesday Muller
released its report on Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn that memo also
providing zero evidence of collusion a
processed crime believe it too fake news
CN n to put facts last and immediately
speculate that the Flynn memo was the
beginning of the end for the president
why is they've been telling us for two
years they just keep recirculating the
same lives take a look the redacted
document if we can put it up people on
Twitter we're literally speculating that
part of this blacked out part it matched
the number of characters in the words
President Donald J Trump that's the
extent to which people are going here
you can see it there to try to figure
out what K for nearly two years
Robert Muller and his merry band of
Democratic donors they have provided
ample fuel for everyone who wants to
destroy the administration D legitimize
a duly elected president now today the
president made this astute evaluation
writing quote without the phony Russia
witch-hunt and with all that we have
accomplished in the last almost two
years tax cuts regulation cuts judges
military vets my approval rating would
be at seventy-five percent rather than
50% just reported by Rasmussen it's
called presidential harassment and when
Robert Muller wraps up his investigation
he shouldn't have any trouble getting a
job at the DNC he's already brought
raised millions of dollars for Democrats
worked overtime full time to destroy
President Trump and he has so many
connections after all he has staff his
entire probe with big-time Democratic
donors Oh an even former Hillary Clinton
lawyer over at the Clinton Foundation
but as the hunt continues well we can
report good news to you tonight a few on
the left are actually finally being held
accountable tomorrow James Comey he will
now testify under oath in front of the
House Judiciary Committee and he will
have a lot to answer for
and much of it surrounds Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn after all remember
call me mccade struck all previously
stated Flynn did not appear to them to
be lying
and now Flynn ultimately pled guilty to
that charge which stem from our federal
government illegally what we had
surveillance on masking no minimization
and then of course leaking raw
intelligence on Flynn's international
communications so what did call me know
about that illegal unmasking and leaking
raw intelligence while Comey prepares
for the hot seat two other anti-trump
operatives are in hot water tonight the
AP is reporting that Democratic lobbyist
Tony Podesta the brother of Clinton
campaign chair John Podesta along with
Obama's former White House Counsel Greg
Craig they are now the subjects of a
federal investigation into their
lobbying efforts for the pro-russia
government of Ukraine no criminal
charges yet filed but the investigation
is reportedly ramping up as we speak
tonight and also breaking tonight a
damning new report from John Solomon at
the hill revealing shocking details
about the investigation into the Clinton
Foundation according to Solomon he'll
join us in a few minutes a 20-17 while a
whistleblower submitted thousands and
thousands of pages of evidence revealing
shocking allegations including quote
serious concerns about legal compliance
improper literally commingling a
personal and charity business and quote
quid pro quo promises made to donors
while Hillary Clinton was Secretary of
State and it is important to note that
the Clinton Foundation raised a whopping
sixty two point nine million dollars in
2016 when a Clinton presidency looked
inevitable the very next year after her
shocking defeat well the foundation only
managed to raise a paltry
while twenty six million dollars now
that is a very suspicious trend given
clear pay-for-play accusations
surrounding the Clinton Foundation now a
spokesperson from the foundation did get
back to us and tell us that it is one of
the most heavily scrutinized charitable
organizations in the world and is
continually subjected to politically
motivated allegations and the foundation
CFO is that I
inappropriate or illegal activities or
we'll see and by the way
Solomon has been very busy this week
last night right here on this program
well we showed you another breaking
report from the hill exposing serious
FISA abuse at the highest level of James
commis FBI and Obama's DOJ and according
to this report the new evidence in the
form of a huge email chain finally
discovered after two years revealing
that quote the FBI was aware before they
secured their first warrant infamous
FISA warrant on Carter page that in fact
there were intelligence community
concerns about the veracity the
reliability of the main evidence the
bulk of evidence that went into the FISA
application in other words the Clinton
bought and paid for Christopher Steele
dossier with Russian lies this smoking
on evidence that high-level FBI
officials willfully committed a fraud
multiple times on FISA Court judges to
obtain and secure a warrant on this
Trump campaign associate Carter page
they never told the FISA judge that the
dossier was bought and paid for by
Hillary Clinton a massive omission or
that its contents were never
corroborated or never verified and that
our own intelligence community had
doubts and yet because of that phony
dossier an American citizen for a year
was spied on by our federal government a
grave miscarriage of justice John
Solomon we'll have more in just a minute
but first we're only weeks out of the
midterms and already believe it or not
the twenty20 election is starting to
heat up
Democrats have an extremely long an
extremely weak field of candidates
likely running to challenge president
Trump and tonight one of the top
contenders far-left zealot Kamala Harris
is cutting ties with the top aide
embroiled in what is a massive
harassment scandal she accepted his
resignation today after the Sacramento
Bee reported the details of a 2016 four
hundred thousand dollar suit and
Harris's claiming she had no prior
knowledge of this massive legal filing
mm-hmm we'll find out overtime now
senator Harris will reportedly decide
over the holidays whether or not
she wants to challenge President Trump
in 2020 and of course Harris and other
top liberals will make gun ownership a
big issue for 2020 make no mistake they
do not believe in the Second Amendment
the way a lot of Americans do
but Democrats should well probably take
note of what happened to Dick's Sporting
Goods
earlier this year remember Dick's
Sporting Goods took a political stance
against the Second Amendment they
actually hired a gun control lobbyists
refused to sell guns to law-abiding
citizens under the age of 21 they
stopped selling AR style long rifles
well now the chain sales have dropped
nearly 4% and its outdoor focus field
and stream stores may soon be closing
their doors
sadly what Dick's and most of the
Democrats often take for granted the
Second Amendment matters to the American
people that's why it is yeah number two
now it's an ever-present check on the
threats of foreign domestic and also
it's more than that to own a gun it's
the right to defend yourself and your
family self-preservation a protection of
all our inalienable rights as Americans
we live in a dangerous and more violent
world every day